2022 began with a major stress test of
President Joe Biden's foreign policy
Russia's invasion of Ukraine as the
United States joined NATO allies in
condemning the attack led by President
Vladimir Putin Biden went a step further
sending billions to the Ukrainian
military and opposing sanctions on the
Kremlin Putin is the aggressor
Putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
so Peter paid a price
U.S ban
price is way up the record 40-year high
inflation forced the Biden White House
to tap into the country's oil reserves
to temporarily bring down fuel costs
believe me
I understand the frustration in July
with fuel prices at record highs Biden
traveled to the middle police to meet
with the Saudi Crown Prince he promised
to make the Royal a pariah over the
killing of U.S based Saudi critic Jamal
khashoggi instead Biden warmly greeted
him with a fist bump but returned to the
United States empty-handed
rowing dissatisfaction over the economy
had pollsters speculating Biden's
Democrats would lose control of Congress
in November midterm elections but
Biden's party hung on narrowly clinging
took control of the Senate still losing
control of the House of Representatives
to Republicans by a small number of
seats will change the dynamic in
congress come January in many ways
Biden's legislative agenda is is over in
the sense that with the house being
controlled by Republicans for the most
part uh the way the party is going their
incentive will be more to block what he
has wants to do rather than to work with
him
2023 will also see a number of
Republicans stepping forward to announce
their plans to take back the White House
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
that includes former president Donald
Trump who's attempting to make history
by becoming only the second U.S
president ever to win non-consecutive
terms one person who has not yet
announced his bid for the White House in
2024 is President Biden at 80 years old
he's America's oldest serving president
and two-thirds of Voters say he should
not seek re-election still the White
House says the president will make his
decision with his family over the
holidays and make his intentions public
sometime in the new year
Kimberly helken Al Jazeera the White
House